the US economy is actually doing okay
it's been chugging along or two percent
unemployment down a four point nine
percent inflation is ticking up a little
bit household formation is going up the
but the markets are completely wide-open
asset prices are up you know I my own
personal view and she does not call me
for advice by the way but you know 25
basis points is a drop in the bucket you
know we don't we always be said to you
all those 25 basis points go really slow
don't worry about it let's just raise
rates so whether it right and I think
you don't want to be behind the eight
ball on this one and you know the Fed
has to maintain credibility and I think
it's time to raise rights normal
normality is a good thing not a bad
thing a straight an economy that's going
to be going on like this for seven years
is a good thing not a bad thing so to me
the return to normal is a good thing and
the rate itself you know gets much more
psychological attention than the actual
economic effect of raising rates so you
would say raising in September or
December doesn't make that much
difference you know yeah I mean I go
soon around later but you know I'll be
the exact timing up to them a and
they've made it clear that they're going
to raise rates and they kind of see the
white of their eyes when they seen it
kind of strong enough and so I'll let
them look at all the factors to decide
what the right time is